was your name jennifer no it's tinnifer
with two wise i used to be jennifer but
then i decided to rebrand myself
oh wait hang on it's on x o'clock
um
well nice to meet you my name's april
and i just wanted to say that your dress
is so cute it's bonks i saw my spinning
instructor wearing it and i was like
shut up where do i get that oh my god
who's your spinning instructor gregory
or winona i go to giannis who are
gregory and winona i've never heard of
them before are they better winona rocks
my world seriously you need to get me in
there like that's a must must must she's
the worst person i've ever met
i want to travel the world with her
you wanted to see me sir
i understand you stopped by the patrol
office's morning briefing yeah officer
deetmore helped me out with my crime
scene so i gave him a little thank you
present
hey deetmore if you're gonna bag
evidence like a five-year-old you should
have the proper tools
to my first police kit
the walkie-talkie blows bubbles
hope you can handle it
he mislabeled the weapon like an idiot
and it almost got filed with the wrong
case he could have won months of work
you humiliated officer deedmore in front
of his peers he submitted an official
complaint against you did he fill it out
on crown no
but he did use a green pen which seems
crazy to me the good news is if you go
down there and apologize
you'll let the whole thing go fine
i'm great at apologizing i'm a very
sweet person
out of my way chunk
babe you look more beautiful right now
than i have ever seen you
wow
just your luck that you're going into
labor on halloween can i get a warm
towel to get that makeup off no i want
it on that's the whole point i put the
makeup on after i went into labor
whatever blows your skirt up okay you
ready to push
wait no babe my birth mix
[Music]
here comes a contraction are you ready
okay i'm ready let's do this
fine what about this guy
no he was scared of everything do you
remember rosa's reaction last time the
printer jammed
[Music]
i'll pay for that
what's your end game here my dear this
is only temporary until i find a way to
keep the shelter open without cutting
the park's budget hey what if i threw
together a pet adoption in one of our
parks would that be cool april that
would be the coolest thing since insync
aerosmith and nelly performed together
at the super bowl halftime show you
i think i may have found a project i'd
actually enjoy doing
helping these cats and dogs they should
be rewarded for not being people
i hate people all right gina we have to
act soon that cold medicine diaz chugged
it was the non-drowsy kind she's all
over the place hey hey hey hey guess
what yeah i got a new lead to ask my
perv about is a drug dealer on state
street whoa why doesn't someone answer
that thought
get it i'll get it
hello i know there's no michael here you
have the wrong number goodbye
i'm michael that's a dumb name but it's
yours and you should be proud of it
because you are the greatest detective
i've ever known no doy do you have no
door where is my file yeah
she's so hopped up on that stuff her
brain's gonna blow i'm gonna interrogate
the perp you keep diaz occupied i don't
want to get near her germ face
permission to lock her in a distant room
no just distract her yes
that is what i will do
come here
i've got to tell you something it's a
secret okay
but i have a lot of stuff to do start
[Music]
yeah she fell asleep five minutes after
i locked her in and she hasn't moved in
the past 10 hours
she talks in her sleep i'm gonna rip
your head off
i'm gonna rip your damn head off grandma
you know what i'm gonna get that
commission going because this inequality
has gone on long enough you know what i
think men are better than women
she's kidding no i'm not they provide
for us and we must obey them because
they are our masters april stop it
leslie you'll never land a bow with that
domineering tone
we must always walk behind the man
that's a puw or portable ultrasonic
weapon
it emits a focused beam of sound which
can disorient and even incapacitate a
perp
so it shoots down is this a trigger yes
but you want to be careful with that
i thought it would be louder it's highly
directional if we're pointed at you
you'd be incredible pain right now
[Music]
oh why is this happening
i can taste my thoughts so i long for a
day when women in government will simply
be seen as people in government but
until then i will work to make pawnee my
wonderful hometown as good as it can be
what do you think i think you should
lose the first line and the last line
and all of the other lines and instead
just walk up to the mic and meow really
loudly for eight minutes okay peralta
what the hell where were you i got
eliminated
excuse me officer yeah sweetheart
sweetheart
seriously hank is how you talk to women
who come in here jimmy jabs i didn't
even make it past one person
okay so i took extensive notes on ways
to maximize our efficiency because we
can't be just as good as a man we have
to be better yeah you're totally right
let's rock this april i love you but i
don't need your sarcasm right now i'm
serious let's get rolling i want to get
into some garbage
what i love garbage
you ever found a dead body in the trash
or body parts like a torso or head
please stay ahead
[Music]
this is stacy knobloch's house i went to
high school with her and she was super
mean to me and now i know
that she dyes her hair i knew that wench
wasn't naturally blonde
oh my god
she has to use prescription strength
deodorant
this is the best day of my life
hey d-more
i'm sorry for making fun of you in front
of everybody
and also for making fun of me behind
your back
didn't know you did that but thank you
for the apology i'm not done also i'm
sorry for making fun of you during my
book club those people don't even know
you that was uncool also i'm sorry it's
okay
i get it no
also i'm sorry that i didn't take the
time to show you how to fix your mistake
come on we can go over it upstairs
thanks
that'd be great
oh one more sorry you're about to see a
drawing i did of you in the elevator
just remember i was really pissed at the
time
so you do a lot of investing we like to
dabble
i recently invested in some shirts i got
at a garage sale
left those at wendy's on the way home
so
the economy
[Laughter]
i've only had arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill everyone in this room and then
myself
very violent eulogy i like it i don't
know why leslie knope's on trial and the
beavers did it beavers did it sit down i
will hold myself and condemn to the cart
i see the color blue just sees blue and
yellow
and i see the letter l r s t w e and b
so basically everyone's first eight
guesses in hangman thank you carlene
your entire life is garbage
hey ladies and gentlemen for the first
time ever in her new part-time job in
the public health department at city
halls and meredith perkins yay oh leslie
this is so nice i put poisonous gas in
one of these balloons so if any of them
pops you may die okay stella all right
no no no no problem okay all right bye
damn
our babysitter's busy the night of
boyle's wedding she's gonna be in her
high school talent show which he's gonna
lose unless her talent is leaving potato
chip crumbs all over terry's couch wait
boyle said a date already yeah he gave
out save the days yesterday
he ain't give you one
i think he's been avoiding me
hey
he didn't invite me to his wedding and
he's scared like a little [ __ ] well
maybe vivian was uncomfortable with you
coming look boyle was in love with you
until a few weeks ago
oh
don't be angry
i'm not angry i think it's funny
[Laughter]
so you're from mongolia
theme
will you take me with you and you go
back there ooh
i love you
did you understand that
did you bring any wolverines look what i
found in hitchcock and scully's trash
can
ice cream spoon son of a [ __ ]
you hungry hungry hippos ate my ice
cream why was this in your trash and who
throws away a spoon it's the easiest
utensil to clean i don't even think it's
ice cream it's probably medicine you
know i'm on lots of medicines rosa
i'm sick all over
this is ice cream and i'm gonna prove it
sarge no it's been in their mouths what
am i doing well i guess your little
investigations hit a dead end i'll be
back
don't
not a problem
i hate moving
let it go
you